[MUSIC PLAYING]
ANU SRIVASTAVA: Hi, everyone.
My name is Anu
Srivastava, and I'm
excited to talk to you today
about the new Cloud Document AI
platform.
Let's dive in to learn more.
Document AI is Google's solution
for understanding documents
in what we consider
dark formats,
such as PDFs, handwritten
forms, and images.
Using the power
of AI, Document AI
turns these
unstructured documents
into structured,
actionable data.
For example, you could
process multipage handwritten
applications with a form parser.
There are also several
specialized parsers already
created, so you could be
batch processing tax documents
by this afternoon.
With structured data, you can
fuel better business decisions,
ensure that your data is
accurate and compliant,
and use your data to meet
customer expectations.
Or hey, maybe
you're just sitting
on a pile of crumpled
receipts you want to digitize.
It's easy to get started
with our specialized parsers,
or bring your own document type
and test out our form parser.
It's all in the new
Document AI platform.
Let's take a look.
The platform, available in
the Google Cloud Console,
is where you can create, modify,
and test out your processor.
We'll walk through an
example on the platform
and talk about what's
going on under the hood
to show you what makes
Document AI special.
Today, we'll demo how to parse
a driver's license application
and show you how to integrate
it into your app or service.
Here is an image on my form.
You can see it's been damaged,
it's crumpled, and just
doesn't have great
image quality.
I want to test out what the
generic form parser will
be able to extract, so I will
create an instance of it here.
I intend to use it in my
application's code on more
documents, so these variables
up here will be important later.
Let's test it out.
You can see the key-value
pairs extracted.
They're now in a digital
format, easy to use.
So what happens under the
hood when you run a document
through a processor?
First, Doc Prep scans,
cleans, and extracts text
from the image using
Google OCR, which
supports over 150 languages.
Next, the words, text,
and visual elements
are used for classification
when required.
Google uses an ensemble
of natural-language models
to extract simple and
compound entities.
When the entities are related,
they're grouped together.
Last but not least,
your document
is packaged up in a
unified document format
and sent back to you.
Now that we understand
what's going on,
let's integrate my processor
into my application.
I'm showing some
Python code today,
but we have client libraries
available in several languages.
This API is incredibly
simple for how much
is happening behind the scenes.
All I need is the
name of my processor,
which I can construct with the
variables from the Console,
and then just the bytes of
the document or the image.
Voila.
Now I can expect all the
spatial and text data back
in an easy-to-use JSON format.
Also, with all of
these key-value pairs,
it's easy to integrate this
data in other services, storage,
or visualization tools
I might be using.
We're excited to
see what you can do
with the power of Document AI.
Get started today,
and let us know
what use cases you're solving.
[MUSIC PLAYING]